[Musique]
péniche contrat tout le monde ça me
redonne été bonasse j'ai tellement
compris pourquoi vous avez vendu 4
millions de disques et pourquoi les gens
vous et vous avez un
un amour de notre prochain non oui oui
j'aime beaucoup ma mère d'ailleurs dit
mais vous êtes comme ça avec les gens
non ben oui même j'aime le monde je
pourrais pas écrire toutes les chansons
que j'écris
si j'aimais pas l'humain et c'est pour
ça aussi que quand les jambes rencontre
après des spectacles devaient toujours
jusqu'à la dernière personne qui atteint
pour signer les autographes pour cette
rencontre là je le trouve gentil lmnp
que voulez vous que je fasse
je très content de vous rencontrer parce
que ça fait quatre ans qu'on vous avait
pas entendu sur disque oui pourquoi une
si longue absence
j'en avais besoin c'était nécessaire à
un moment donné on s'égare un petit peu
plusieurs personnes peuvent se garer moi
ça m'est arrivé je savais plus au juste
où est ce que je t'ai bien j'avais de la
difficulté à trouver la linda que
j'aimais être
c'est comme si j'aimais - mon métier je
me sentais moins bien même dans ma
famille je me disais mais comment
comment je fais pour être une bonne
artiste comment je fais pour être une
bonne mère le doute s'est comme emparée
de moi un moment donné dans le couvent
de la quarantaine et je me disais mais
je savais plus comment aimer as potiche
d'exposer light donc je l'avais perdu la
linda et il a fallu que je prenne un
temps d'arrêt b tout à coup
et tout à coup tout le monde sait
au lieu de me dire que vous avez perdu
l'aller n'da la langue vous l'avez
retrouvé comment à quel moment dans un
café ici à 6 à votre piano ya des gros
changements dans ma vie en particulier
en 2017
j'ai perdu mon papa c'est quand même une
grosse étape dans la vie de perdre son
papa
surtout quand c'est le plus fort et ça
ça a été quelque chose
ti et j'avais déjà commencé un genre de
remise en question à ce moment alors ça
c'est arrivé comme une surprise pape a
eu un cancer c'est allé vite vite vite
en quelques mois ils étaient partis
comment te fais moment pour trouver le
bon que tu l'a connue comment tullaye
mais coupe au juste dans les semaines
qui ont précédé son départ
je commence à écrire avec papa parce que
comment je faisais face à sa voix à la
mort de mon père en lui parlant à lui
mon réflexe a été de créer et donc lui
donnait des rimes moche je faisais des
chansons avec avec série muller je
m'arrangeais pour tout les toutes les
preuves les rimes qui me sortait et je
les place est dans les chansons que ça
donnait des chansons qui vont faire
partie de dés prochain album j'enfile la
scène comme des running je pourrais
courir ma vie entière
franchir de simple interligne avec des
pieds qui axe
pourquoi annoncer aux albums en mai sans
enjeu cela semble gigantesque comme
proches ici commenté steven bossard
plaisir dans la vie il à vie courte
ça fait partie de moi je me dis pourquoi
retenir ça puis peut-être dans cinq ans
je serai plus capable de chanter je suis
pas ôter la vie ça va vite puis des fois
il peut m'arriver quelque chose ce point
n'avait c'est n'importe quoi ça peut
arriver à tout le monde donc ça peut
m'arriver à moi je rentre à 54 et le
dollar à 60 ans 65
peut-être que je serai plus capable
faire le métier comme je capable de
faire maintenant
pourquoi ne pas en profiter c'était le
soir 8 heures ou sous sol de l'église
là où les coeurs tour à tour fait un
striptease je pense que je peux appeler
votre nouveau projet votre deuxième
carrière parce que vous avez fait un
jour peut-être pas un ménage mais une
réorganisation
c'est bien dit parce que je prenais des
risques financiers voulant donner dans
ce projet leur tâche en jouant de
musique et oui j'ai vraiment pris mes
économies j'ai produit ce projet l'homme
moi même
il y avait un coussin les dieux plus de
coussin mais c'est correct
c'est correct parce que ma richesse à
moi puis mon héritage les tâches que je
peux laisser je pense c'est des chansons
à la lueur d'une dizaine de briquets
avec entre nous deux que le courant
passait
ces six ça me représente c'est ce que je
suis mes chansons sont une grande grande
partie de la femme que je suis je pense
c'est chez qu'il faut pas aussi
dentifrice up qui à la fin de mes jours
mes chansons voudront rien dire que je
vais faire face à moi-même fille je vais
peut-être trouver encore plus qu échouer
la vraie linda pour le moment j'ai
l'impression que mes chansons racontent
beaucoup de la femme que je suis
c'est pareil onze albums dont chansons
que je les ai faites puis je les aime
mes gardes déjà moi je suis satisfait
après ce cd bonus lorsque ce que la vie
vaut m'offrir une rencontre comme celle
qu'on a aujourd'hui
ça me comble merci pour la belle
rencontre je pense que le score composer
une petite touche j'ai apporté ma
victoire à qui on se méfie merci à toi
comprenez tout tout le monde
que je puisse avoir envie
deux maîtres du petit m'en demandez lui
faire croire au paradis